President Trump is again facing off with
a powerful senator from his own party
the dispute with Senate Foreign
Relations chairman bob corker may put
his political agenda at risk the
president tweeted yesterday senator bob
Corker begged me to endorse him for
reelection in tennessee i said no and he
dropped out corker responded this way
it's a shame the White House has become
an adult daycare center
someone obviously missed their shift
this morning hours later the president
challenged Democrats to support his
immigration goals in order to so-called
keep the daca protection for young
undocumented immigrants major Garrett is
at the White House with more major good
morning good morning when President
Trump ended daca but signaled he was
open to a legislative compromise we
reported at the time but too soon the
White House would follow up with very
tough immigration proposals will now
they're here and the timing reflects a
grim political reality here at the White
House where aides are significantly
worried tax reform will falter leaving
the president with no significant
accomplishments in his first year and at
the end of that first year negotiating
with Democrats to legalize an Obama
error executive action many Trump
supporters regard as amnesty the White
House sent Congress and immigration wish
lists meant to reassure president
Trump's base that he hasn't gone soft on
the issue that helped propel him to the
presidency the administration told
Congress any daca deal must fund the
border wall crackdown on sanctuary
cities imposed new skills-based legal
immigration criteria and speed up
deportation procedures democratic
leaders said the proposals go far beyond
what is reasonable this proposal fails
to represent any attempt at compromise
they wrote referring to earlier talks
with the president the Democratic leader
said wall funding was explicitly ruled
out of the negotiations that wasn't the
president's only clash on Capitol Hill
senator bob Corker a key Republican ally
told the New York Times that mr. Trump
was treating the presidency like a
reality show with reckless threat toward
other countries that could set the
nation on the path to world war 3 and
that tweets hurt us as it relates to
negotiations this after the president
tweeted early Sunday I would fully
expect corker to be a negative voice and
stand in the way of our great agenda
didn't have the guts to run mr. Trump
wrote referring to corkers recent
decision not to seek a third Senate term
corker said the president tweets out
things that are not true and that the
vast majority of our caucus understands
what we are dealing with here last week
the senator broke with mr. Trump and
sided with Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson when their strained
relationship exploded into public view
secretary tell arson secretary mattis
and chief of staff Kelly are those
people that helped separate our country
from chaos the president in the coming
weeks will need every Senate Republican
vote on the budget on tax reform and
possibly even on health care senator
corker is also central to congressional
oversight of the Iran deal giving him
leverage on domestic and international
relations making the timing of the
president's spat with corker all the
more curious Charlie thanks major